[Applaudissements]
peut-être que certains d'entre vous vous
connaissez justement par cette
journaliste qui fait des photos coeur
alors c'est vrai c'est une journée ce
passionné qui fait des coeurs avec les
doigts alors c'est vrai qu'au premier
abord je le partage ça peut être
complètement curieux et bien pourtant la
signification de ce symbole vient d'un
héritage mais d'où vient-il
qu'est ce qu'il signifie et surtout quel
est mon message
qu'est ce que je veux transmettre platon
disait aux enfants il faut laisser un
héritage de conscience plutôt que d'or
et bien moi mon héritage de conscience
est parti d'une drôle de baby sitter
j'ai été élevé et bert fait par le plus
cool des professeurs de développement
durable quand vous pensez à michael
jackson
ça vous évoque quoi billie jean thriller
bad le moonwalk
et bien moi c'est pas uniquement ce que
j'ai perçu chez cet artiste
il m'a transmis ses engagements à
travers ses clips complètement choquant
et ses paroles dans lesquelles il
dénonçait la destruction de la planète
notamment la déforestation la
destruction de notre biodiversité
notamment les massacres qu on peut faire
aux éléphants avec le marché de l'ivoire
mais également toutes les tyrannies
engendrés par les guerres et l'écrivent
son urgence
c'était de soigner la planète il
le world vous souvenez alors bien
évidemment au départ j'ai pas tout de
suite compris la profondeur de ses
messages j'étais haute comme trois
pommes et pas du tout encore bio et
équitable mais son héritage a marqué mon
intention et surtout cette phrase si tu
veux changer le monde commence par
changer la personne dans le miroir ça
vous parle est ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé de prendre une décision en
suivant votre instinct en écoutant votre
coeur eh bien c'est ce que j'ai fait à
26 ans j'ai pas du tout continuer mon
poste de journalistes dans une rédaction
et je suis parti en quête de sens et
j'ai commencé à me regarder dans le
miroir
mais cette fois ci pas pour danser je
suis parti en quête de sens et je
commence à me poser des questions à quoi
je sers qu'est-ce que je fais là et face
à mon miroir
qu'est-ce que je peux faire et c'est là
qu'est ce les choses se sont enchaînées
pour moi avec deux bouleversements
majeurs dans ma vie le premier est venue
de mon désir d'aller sur le terrain du
passé du clip à la réalité c'est à dire
partir en mission humanitaire
en moins d'un an je me suis retrouvé au
bangladesh pour une enquête
journalistique avec une ong
et c'est là que j'étais immergé dans les
camps de réfugiés les apatrides
winga que vous devez connaître je ne
vous le cache pas cette mission m'a
profondément touchés bouleversés et
marqué à jamais mais si je vous en parle
ce soir j'en ai des frissons c'est aussi
parce que cette mission m'a sauvé la vie
en fait avant de partir j'ai dû faire
une visite médicale
et là on ne décèle un souffle au coeur
en souffre le coeur mais c'est pas grave
je pars quand même mission madame de
retour je vais voir un cardiologue pour
la première fois de ma vie est là il
m'annonce que j'ai le coeur qui a une
taille anormale alors je savais déjà que
moi même j'étais pas normal
alors si en plus moqueurs sim était et
donc du coup je fais des analyses
je passe des examens conclusion je dois
me faire opérer d'urgence et quelques
semaines plus tard on me pose ça ce
bijou de coeur on appelle ça dans le
jargon un parapluie médicale il évalue
aujourd'hui il bouche le trou que
j'avais entre mes deux oreillettes
c'est le tissu manquant que j'avais pas
je suis né mal formés en fait et même
pas 24 heures après je ressemblais à ça
la photo que j'envoyais mes amis de
cannes a quelques-uns qui sont dans la
salle ils sont faits viennent avec leurs
bracelets aux poignets
mais alors que faire maintenant dans
cette nouvelle vie avec ce bijou de
coeur et bien encore une fois j'ai
écouté mon coeur moi j'ai été sauvé
j'ai été soignée mais c'est pas le cas
de tout le monde c'est pas le cas de
beaucoup de monde dit de la planète
alors j'ai décidé cette fois d'aller au
delà que d'être consciente
j'ai décidé d'agir à mon échelle à ma
modeste échelle et c'est à partir de ce
moment là que les rites hard l'héritage
de michael jackson s'est révélé être de
façon consciente dans ma vie je suis
devenu une journaliste green n positive
pour notre planète qui comme vous le
savez
est aussi belle que fragile ça veut dire
quoi c'est moi qui me suis auto proclamé
que green elle positive beaucoup
d'imagination après sa green ça veut
dire d'aller prendre conscience qu'il
faut protéger notre magnifique planète
qu'il faut militer pour le respect de la
nature qu'il n'y a pas d'humanité son
environnement que l'homme est
interdépendant la nature ce n'est pas le
contraire donc être green est écologiste
c'est une pensée logique pour la survie
de l'humanité c'est respecter notre
nature notre maison mère être positive
c'est mettre en lumière des initiatives
des personnes inspirante qui veulent
changer le monde qui trouve des
solutions c'est porteur de solutions
d'un monde meilleur
moi j'appelle et schenker mon but est
bien c'est d'informer d'informer le plus
grand nombre possible que des solutions
existent peut-être en bas de chez vous
s'informer mais s'est aussi inspiré
inspiré chacun de pouvoir agir à sa
propre échelle et le coeur dans tout ça
est bien le coeur et le milieu de
chacune de mes rencontres de chacun de
mes interviews
la faute au coeur que vous avez vu au
départ maintenant vous comprenez le sens
et j'ai fait avec des centaines et des
centaines de personnes à travers le
monde avec des figures spirituelles les
humanistes des écologistes des
scientifiques des explorateurs des
aventuriers des entrepreneurs sociaux
des enfants et j'ai partagé je continue
de partager leurs histoires sur mon blog
en radio en télé dans mon livre et dans
des conférences comme celle ci
d'ailleurs avec vous ce soir je vais
vous raconter une histoire que j'ai pas
encore raconté
c'est l'une de mes dernières rencontres
c'était il ya quelques mois je suis
parti en ethiopie j'ai fait la rencontre
d'un petit garçon
ces petits garçons il m'a fait un cadeau
d'une valeur inestimable
il m'a offert une tomate et savais même
pas que j'étais végétarienne est ce que
vous connaissez
ecosia echoes ya c'est un moteur de
recherche qui plantent des arbres tout
est possible avec les nouvelles
technologies êtes d'accord
eh bien je suis parti en mission de
presse avec eux un voyage de presse et
le but c'était de voir l'impact des
arbres sur les communautés rurales et
voir comment ces communautés pouvait
vivre en autosuffisance grâce à ces
arbres les arbres de nombreuses vertus
que vous connaissez sans doute dont
celui d'améliorer le cours d'eau alors
je me suis rendu dans l'une de ces
communautés
là on est à une heure et demie d'addis
abeba au sud-est et là sur cette colline
qui s'appelle gang or il
j'ai pu voir que des arbres plantés sur
cette colline a permis justement d'avoir
des cours d'eau plus conséquent du coup
ces paysans ont pu faire des cultures
dont celle de la tomate les tomates sont
les choses les plus précieuses que ces
paysans postede pourquoi plus il ya
d'arbres feuillus llado plus il ya d'eau
pluviale tomates puis il ya thomas
depuis ils ont des revenus il plus ils
ont des revenus plus ils peuvent
diversifier leur alimentation est donc
être en meilleure santé
ce petit garçon c'est celui qui est en
bas à droite il s'appelle tallec ou
jamie c'est lui qui m'a offert cette
tomate
pendant que cette journaliste en plein
milieu des champs habillé n'importe
comment faisait son blog les vidéos pour
dire regardez en plantant des arbres
vous les 21 autres
eh bien vous regardez les paysans
peuvent irriguer et notamment faire des
tomates
hélas non comme ça il me donne certes au
mad est certain à ce moment précis que
j'ai compris qu effectivement plantés en
arbre ça change le monde disait wang
gorille ma taille
la première femme africaine à l'été
kényane qui a eu le prix nobel de la
paix pour son engagement en faveur de
l'environnement
ça change le monde mais comment ça
change le monde quand il ya des arbres
la biodiversité rené les seuls
s'enrichissent les cours d'eau sont plus
conséquents du coup on peut faire des
cultures
du coup avec ces cultures on peut lutter
contre l'insécurité alimentaire
personne justement peuvent être en
meilleure santé et ça peut même
permettre de donner accès à l'éducation
filles ça leur évite de faire des heures
et des heures et des kilomètres des
kilomètres pour aller chercher de l'eau
pour leur famille pour vivre ou survivre
c'est ça qui m'anime dans cette nouvelle
vie c'est mettre en lumière des
initiatives comme celle-ci qui non
seulement permettre d'aider des
populaires et des populations des
communautés à les rendre plus justement
plus pérennes plus durable et en plus ça
préserve l'environnement
cet exemple simple est à la fois
touchants c'est ce que je fais c'est ce
que je fais c'est des mises en lumière
c'est ça que je fais dans cette nouvelle
vie avec cette nouvelle renaissance
c'est mettre en lumière des initiatives
comme celle ci également partager des
histoires d'hommes qui n'ont parfois
qu'une tomate à partager alors depuis
trois ans ça fait plus de trois ans
maintenant que je parcours le monde
tant que je peux pour rencontrer tous
ces acteurs du changement tout c'est ce
challenge baker ils sont tous très
différents
ça peut être un chef de tribu dans
autochtones qui vient de colombie
d'amazonie ça peut être un entrepreneur
social français berlinois américain ils
sont très différents mais ont une seule
chose en commun au minimum ils ont pris
conscience que l'héritage que nous
allons laisser à nos futures générations
dépend de chacun non de chacun de nos
faits et gestes au quotidien et je vais
même dire qu'ils partagent l'étude du
moins qui comprennent cette citation qui
est devenu mon mantra de michael jackson
si tu veux changer le monde commence par
changer la personne n'ignore le coeur de
tous etienne jaumet coeur bat il bat
pour eux mais pas seulement il pas
également pour la planète
ce sont eux qui sont en train de
façonner le monde de demain c'est vous
ces noms là même si chaque geste peut
paraître une goutte
imaginez près de 8 milliards de gouttes
réunis pour former un océan du mieux
vivre ensemble
mais alors que faire des zooms demain
matin qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire et
bien vous regarder dans le miroir mettre
en lumière un challenge mais coeur une
personne indifférente à côté de chez
vous
créez votre propre initiative faire du
bénévolat aidez votre prochain avoir une
consommation plus durable plus
responsable plus beau le cube plus
biologique plus équitable c'est aussi
simple que ça en fait il est là votre
avenir
il est là notre héritage il est la
portée de notre coeur qu'il soit sain ou
soigner alors ensemble faisons battre le
coeur du monde merci
[Applaudissements]